[LOGO MUSIC]
FRANCESCO CARUCCI: Personally,
I'm a graphics engineer.
I've been Making games
since 1999, give or take.
And I always wrote
my graphics engines.
The big takeaway for me
here is that, first, I
don't have to do it anymore.
I can just write the
shaders, I can just
write the form part
because Unity helps me
with all the legwork.
And we're going to
talk about, first,
all the editor and
workflow improvements
that Unity is bringing
to the table recently.
Unity has been
really, really good
at presenting in the editor
how the game looks like.
I worked on games where the
iteration time was something
like, I make a change,
not me, but the actors
make a change in the
level, compile lighting,
two days later see
how it looks like.
Well, in Unity, that's
not how it works.
You can see immediately the
content creator is working on.
But now, Unity is
getting better and better
at also showing on device
how the game looks like.
I'm a huge fan and I always
ask all my content creators
to look at the
game on the device
because a model texture and
level might look wonderful
on your Photoshop or
on your 3D package
might look wonderful
on the editor,
but the device is a different
beast, different monitor,
everything is different.
Just check on device, and
Unity is helping here as well.
Iteration is key.
And Unity makes it
as fast as possible.
Then we're going to
talk about graphics,
which is my favorite subject
because I'm a graphics
engineer.
And here, Unity is
bringing to the table
the possibility to address
the whole range of devices
from low power devices,
low performance devices,
to high end devices.
It offers low quality renders
to address these low end devices
and high fidelity renderings
to address the high end AAA
kind of use case.
And finally, at the end, we're
going to talk about Google
Play support and
how we're writing
as Google our own
plugins to help
you develop a ship on Android.
So I'm very excited to leave
the stage to JC from Unity.
Thank you.
JC CIMETIERE: Hello, everyone.
So glad to be here today.
So before, so my name is JC.
I'm a product manager at Unity.
I focus primarily
on mobile platforms.
And, yeah.
I'm going to talk about Unity.
And before I get
into there, I just
want to do a quick
raise of hands.
So who's using Unity currently?
I saw a few people who
didn't raise their hand.
What are you doing?
Come on.
There's a free version to try.
No commitment, just try.
It's easy to get started.
So, more seriously, Unity
started more than 10 years ago
with a vision in
mind that we wanted
to democratize game development,
really help creators
to realize their vision.
And since then, well,
a few million users
have tried and use Unity
and keep using Unity,
but also we've
gone beyond games.
So Unity is also now powering
other industries, like film,
automotive, simulation,
architecture, and many more.
And this is because
basically our technology
is a real time 3D engine,
3D development platform.
You can do 2D if you want.
It's just removing
one dimension,
which is fairly easy.
And Unity's focus
at the beginning
was really on the
creator, helping
you to realize your vision.
We've always thought
that the world
is a better world the
more creators we have.
But we've also realized that
creating is only one thing.
You want to go to the next
step, and the next step
is when you create for serious,
you want to make it a business
and you want to live from that.
We're trying to enable success.
And the way we do that we offer
additional options for Unity
users to basically manage
the lifecycle of their games.
And in particular, we offer a
service to manage multiplayer.
So if you want to create
a multiplayer game,
we have all the things
you need to do with Unity.
And finally, on
mobile, if you choose
to monetize through
advertising, for example,
we have also a
very strong network
that can be used to
help you be successful.
So just a very quick intro
to give you a sense of Unity
is not just a game engine, it's
actually way more than that.
But to that, we're going to
focus on the creation path.
And as Fran said
in the intro, we're
going to stop looking
at workflow improvement.
And I want to remind
some of the goals really
that are critical to us.
So, first of all, I
didn't mention it,
but one of the key thing in
addition to democratizing game
development is also to be
a cross-platform engine.
Basically, you build once
and you deploy everywhere.
And I'll be honest.
Deploying everywhere requires
always a [INAUDIBLE] fork.
But we're trying to make that
work as painless as possible.
The second thing is about
general productivity.
We want to give you the
tools that makes you go
do things the
fastest as possible.
And we'll go through a
few of those new things.
And iteration on
device is really
call to the investment
we're meeting these days
to help you work in the editor,
do things really fast, but also
being able to see the
result of your iteration,
your work on device.
Because, yes, mobile devices
are a little bit tricky
and there are many, many kinds
of devices in the Android
ecosystem.
The diversity is so broad
that testing on device
is definitely a must.
So I'm going to go
through a list of features
that are coming.
Or just landing in Unity
and try to give you
a sense of the latest
and greatest that
are helping in those
areas that we mentioned.
So, first of all,
in 19.1, we are now
shipping with Unity the right,
the correct Android SDK,
Android NDK.
And actually,
starting with 18.2,
starting with the
last version of 2018,
we included the open JDK.
Which means now when you
install Unity for Android
and you've done with
the installation,
you can actually build
and deploy right away.
You won't have to do
any configuration.
It's ready to go.
And, if you're an advanced user,
you know what you're doing,
you can actually do more
advanced configuration and set
things up the way you want.
But to get started
really fast, that's built
in via the Hub, which is the
new way to install Unity and get
all the different components.
In 19.2, we're working
on a new feature
to enable you to
manage notification
from Unity directly.
So you won't have to deal
with the low-level system
operations.
And that's a way to do cross
platform notification for iOS
and Android.
It's going to be
delivered as a package
and it's in preview currently.
So I didn't mention in 19.1
the safer and the notch
because I have a
special slide for that.
So starting with
Unity 19.2, we are
adding the feature that enables
you to detect the cut-out area.
And the safe area is where
you can safely place content.
It's not going to
be behind a notch.
And so now, via
code, it can actually
detect what are the
different areas,
the safe area, no problem.
It tells you where
the cutout is,
and then you know
where the space is.
So by the way, do you
know what form that is?
Nobody knows?
Anybody want to guess?
OK.
So that's Pixel 3 XL.
So, if you're running that
code, actually, exactly
that code on a Pixel 3
XL, this is what happens.
So the first thing, you start by
defining your screen safe area.
And that's the red rectangle
that's been drawn here.
And then, you define a
valuable that is the cutouts,
and there can be
multiple cutouts.
And you do a simple loop.
You check that there's
at least one cutout,
and there's one right here.
We're drawing a green rectangle.
So this is really super easy
to use and very convenient
if you want to maximize
the space that you
have on your phones.
And, by the way, that
feature also works on iPhone.
So you're going to get the same
code working across platform.
Profiling.
It's always challenging
when you make a game.
It works well on one device,
and then on another device maybe
it doesn't work that well.
So there's a lot of
profiling option.
Unity has a pretty
advanced profiler
that allows you to look
inside the game from Unity's
standpoint.
But what we've done
is with Unity 19.1,
we've actually instrumented
the build that we make.
So, when you run a
Unity game on Android,
Systrace, which is one of
the advanced profiling tool,
will actually know inside the
Unity app what's going on.
So, on that
screenshot, it shows,
from Systrace, which is a native
Android profiling tool, what
are the different thread in
Unity, what is the rendering
thread, what is the main
thread, what is a choreographer.
And so you can detect from
the outside what's going wrong
or what are the
problems, potentially,
that could be caused by some
interference with the other
applications running on the
system or some weird thing that
you cannot detect
from within Unity.
So super useful and
that's available now.
So another more advanced
way of debugging
is using Android Logcat.
It's a very powerful, very
verbose debugging tool.
What we've done is actually we
brought Logcat inside Unity,
so you don't have to do
any command line tool.
And it's also super
useful because we give you
a lot of information that you
can filter and look through.
So I have a little
scenario here.
So this is a Logcat window
running inside Unity.
So once you've
connected a phone,
you're going to start seeing
all the Logcat event coming
to Unity.
And of course, that's
maybe a little too much.
So the first thing I
want to do is filter
and I'm going to filter
by the application that's
running on the device.
So I've deployed
this little game,
and so I'm going to
just select this one.
And now, the Logcat
gives me only the events
that are generated
by this application.
So in this case, this
is the legal card game.
And as you can see at the
bottom, the deck of cards
is empty and obviously
something wrong happened.
And yes, this is a game that's
using asset bundles that
are hosted somewhere else.
And I forgot to build my assets.
So the game starts, tries
to download the assets,
the assets are not here.
It generates errors that you
can see directly in Logcat.
So in that case, I can detect
very quickly what's going wrong
and then fix it really quickly.
And by the way, the
screenshot is also
taken directly from Unity.
There's the little button
here, Capture Screen.
It's going to take a
screenshot of what's
running on the device, and
you can save it locally
on your machine.
Small feature, but
super convenient.
So, now, when you're
deploying to your device,
you try and then you
want to make a change.
So we've introduced
a new feature
in Unity 19.1 for Android
that allows you to do
super fast iteration on code.
So here's the scenario.
So the video just started.
So we make a build.
So we have a little sample game.
You may have seen it
this is one we were
using in our teaching material.
It's Infinite Runner.
So the first build
takes about a minute.
It was a little fast.
So the score starts at zero.
And I like to cheat, so what
I'm going to do, I want to do,
I want to change a code
and start the game at 10.
So I'm go going to the code,
do a little quick change.
And at this point, I don't
want to rebuild the whole game.
So what I'm going
to do, I'm going
to use this option,
script only, so I'm
going to recompile just the
code, not touch any asset.
I'm going to ask Unity,
OK, rebuild the code,
recompile the code, and
just push the new library.
And so in this case, I don't
even rebuild the new APK.
I just recompile my library,
push it to the device,
and it takes 18 seconds
instead of one minute.
And as you can see, when
you restart the game,
the game will look
for the new library
and take it to an account.
And then, as you
can see, I cheated,
now I'm starting
with 10 points ahead.
It's available in Unity
2019.1 that shipped last week.
And that is really fast
when you want to do a code
iteration on your code only.
AR.
So who's doing AR
development in the room?
A few.
Great.
So one of the key thing is
very focused on our desire
to provide cross
platform support.
We've brought AI
foundation, which
is a new layer and
Unity that really
gives that cross platform
feature across iOS and Android.
But, also, what we're
doing is, by giving you
this kind of common APIs to
do all the common things,
we're also providing
some extensions
so that every platform that
has some specific features
are brought directly to you.
So you have them right in Unity.
But for all the
common things, you
don't have to worry
about the differences
between those platforms.
That's the first thing.
Next, we are introducing
in 19.1 a set of features.
The first one is the
possibility to record a session.
So if you are playing with
your app that you've built
and exploring the
world, you can record
all the events that happen
and replay that session
and use it, for
example, as the test
script for further test if
you've made some changes
to verify everything is OK.
Next, in 19.2, we're working
on editor simulation.
So in this case,
you don't even need
to have a device connected
to the Unity Editor.
You can actually simulate inputs
and a real world around you.
So, again, that's a
way to iterate really
fast even without having
a device connected.
So I skip the AR remote
because I have a video.
So the AR remote is a way to
combine the power of the Unity
Editor, and having a phone
connected to your development
machine.
So in that case, the way it
works, you connect your phone
to the Unity editor.
And then, the phone
is streaming the world
to the editor and all the
information, location,
planning, detection,
and everything.
And so you end up basically
working directly in the editor,
but you have the phone that is
acting as a device capturing
the world.
So you can iterate
really fast and do
a lot of testing
without having to build
and then wait for the
build to be ready and play
with the phone.
So we can really combine that
and that's super powerful
to iterate very fast.
So let's talk about graphics.
As I said earlier, Unity was
created more than 10 years ago.
And when we made the
first iterations of Unity,
we've built a really
powerful graphics engine,
but we also built
it in a way that's
fairly black box in the
sense that there's not
a lot of hooks to tweak it
to really get the engine
to go any direction you want.
So a couple years
ago, we started
thinking about a new
rendering engine,
and we built this new
engine with the idea
that we want to give you a lot
of power, a lot of control,
and also a lot of flexibility.
So what we've done is
basically created the core
of the rendering pipeline
that is built in C++.
And around that core,
we have a series
of scripts that are
written in C Sharp that
will take care of all the
steps that are happening
in the rendering pipeline.
So that would give you full
control of the rendering
pipeline, but on the other
hand, your responsibility
is limited to writing
code in C Sharp
and having to choose the
different steps you want.
So you can have a really
customized rendering process,
you control resource usage,
you can control performance.
And that is all great for
people like Francesco, who likes
to create a rendering pipeline.
But out of the box we give
you two rendering pipelines
that are ready to use.
And the first one that we call
lightweight render pipeline
is actually out of preview,
so final in Unity 19.1.
And this is basically the
more universal pipeline
that is designed with
performance in mind
and that will work really
well across all platforms.
There's a big focus on
making that pipeline super
efficient on mobile,
but also it's
really easy to
configure this pipeline
to add extra post-processing
or to remove post-processing
or to add your
custom steps if you
want to do special things
during the rendering pipeline.
So this is the one that is
really recommended for mobile.
And we have another
rendering pipeline
which is called high definition
render pipeline, which
is basically the one we use for
games that are designed to run
on PC console exclusively.
That's the pipeline that
is used in film when
we want to do a simulation.
So Unity has been used to do--
we've shown some demo to
show a Lexus car in the world
that you don't even know if
it's a real one or a fake one.
And that's the
rendering pipeline
that's being used for those.
And the main difference is that
the high definition rendering
pipeline is actually heavily
relying on the GPO compute
processing, which is
somehow available on mobile
but not on all mobile for sure,
and even on high end mobile
has some limitation.
So to drill down a little
bit on the graphics roadmap
specifically for what applies
to mobile, so the few features
that I wanted to discuss
today, the first one
is one we call dynamic
resolution, which
is available for the
lightweight render pipeline now.
And what it enables you
is, basically, at runtime,
you can decide to reduce a
little bit the resolution
at which you are rendering
so that you can really
save on bandwidth on the GPU,
on the CPU, and on memory.
And you just reduce by a
few percent your resolution
and you blip to the full
screen at the very last step.
And this feature required
us to use Vulcan.
I wanted to mention
the fact that we've
been working a lot on Vulcan
with Google with all the OEMs
to make sure Vulcan
gets better and better.
And so with 19.1,
actually by default,
when you create a
new project it's
going to be Vulcan, the primary
graphic API that is selected.
And, of course, you can decide
to choose something different.
But we truly believe
that Vulcan is
at the stage where
it is seriously
a good solution, especially
for the latest devices.
I wanted to mention
also a feature that is
called optimized frame pacing.
And that's a feature
that actually
has been developed
by Google that we've
integrated inside Unity.
So what it does, basically, it
provides a better orchestration
of the distribution
of the frames
during the cycle of generating
the frames for the game.
And Android is a pretty
complex operating system
and this feature makes your game
frame rate even more smooth.
And so that's for
me the opportunity
to highlight the partnership
that Unity and Google have
been having for four years now.
And, really, we
work super closely
to make sure Unity
works well on Android.
But also Google is listening
to us game engine creators
with the input we can
give to their team,
so Android gets
better over time.
So it's really a
rich collaboration,
a rich discussion,
and hopefully you'll
get the benefits as
game creators of all
those collaborations.
And I wanted to finish
on Shader Graph.
So you mentioned you
like to write shaders,
I hate-- actually, no,
I can't write a shader.
I can't, I'm sorry.
I used to be a developer, but
shaders is out of my league
for many reasons.
First of all, it's
pretty advanced math
and you have to
have the capability
of seeing the
pixels on the screen
and translating that
vision into code and math.
This is really hard.
Some people can do
it, most cannot.
And of course, from a
productivity standpoint writing
a shader by hand is not
the most productive.
So we have created this
new tool, Shader Graph,
which is out of preview
with the 19.1, that really
enables any artist to combine
using a node graph based
system.
A bunch of steps and it's a big
tool box with a lot of options,
but it's really
super easy to use.
You can unlock them.
That's from the screenshot.
You can take a model and put it
as the output the end result,
and then you combine
all the different nodes
to create the effect
that you want.
And in 19.1, we've
added one feature,
which is nestable graphs.
So if we end up
having a giant graph,
then you can actually
create subsections,
make them a subgraph, and
then just connect them
with the rest of
your graph, which
makes it much more readable and
also makes some parts reusable.
In 19.2, we are introducing
the half precision toggle.
For example, in
this scenario, where
you're planning to
make a game that
will work not only on mobile,
but also on PC and console,
you actually won't
have precision shaders
on mobile and then full
precision on bigger platforms.
But writing shader graphic
in a switch of a toggle
so we can see the effect
of changing the precision
level on your shader.
So visually you get
the result to see
if changing that
precision is not
going to create any trouble.
And much more is coming.
At the end of the slide,
we have a little video
with a series of cool
games made with Unity.
But with that,
take it away, Ben.
BEN GABLE: All right.
Thanks, JC.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Ben Gable, I am
a developer advocate here
at Google and game developer.
I work with game
developers every day
to help them make
awesome games on Android
and I'm here today to talk a
little bit about Android app
bundles.
And specifically for
Unity developers,
how you can utilize
this awesome tool
and how you should
totally be using it
on your production games.
So to start off, I want to kind
of get a quick show of hands.
How many of you are familiar
with Android app bundles?
OK.
That's a good number.
And of those people that
are familiar with it,
how many are actually using
Android app bundles instead
of an APK?
OK.
There's a lot less
that time around.
So hopefully at the
end of this talk,
there's a lot more hands that
will go up in the near future.
So what is an
Android app bundle?
So Android app bundles
are an awesome tool
that save you from having
to manage multiple APKs
or from having to put all
of your stuff into one APK
and keep it under some
kind of size limit
to support all these different
device configurations.
So, for example, you either
have to have multiple APKs, one
for the different architectures
that are out there, x86, arm,
you might have multiplied
because for high resolution
assets, or an API gave
for low resolution assets,
or you're trying to
fit all that together
into one universal APK
that fits all devices.
And so what app
bundles let you do
is instead of building
these multiple APKs
or splitting it
all into one, you
build an app bundle
which has everything
needed for your
game to run across
all these different devices.
And then, instead of uploading
an APK to Google Play,
you just upload the app bundle.
And what Google Play is
going to do on the back end
is basically take
your app bundle
and it's going to generate
and sign and distribute
an optimized APK
specifically for the device
that somebody is playing on.
So, for example, if
somebody is coming along
and they want to download
your game on an x86 device,
they're only going to
get the x86 versions
of your native libraries and
they won't get the arm versions
there.
So it saves a lot of space
on the users' end as well.
And another cool
aspect of Android
app bundles is that right now
on the app store on Google Play,
if you upload an APK, you have
to keep it under 100 megabytes
unless--
if you're over
100 megabytes, you
have to use expansion files.
With app bundles, we've
increased that limit
to 150 megabytes.
So there's a lot of
benefits using app bundles.
And I'm here to specifically how
easy it is in Unity to do this
and why you should
be totally using it.
So the idea behind app bundles
is all of these benefits
and saving you the
hassle of managing
all these multiple APKs
with none of the overhead.
So if you're using
Unity 2018.3 and above,
app bundles are super
simple to build.
I'll show you in a second.
Or if you're potentially
exporting to Android Studio,
if using Android studio 3.2
and above, it's just the
build option to build an app
bundle instead of an APK.
So in Unity out of the box,
what you're going to get,
as I mentioned before, is
when you build an Android app
bundle, Unity is
going to generate it
and it's going to allow
you to basically provide
optimized builds for
different native library
and running on
different architectures.
So you're going to get 64
and 32-bit arm support,
as well as x86 native
library support.
Now, you can also
if you've set up
your game to have your
localization files in kind
of the standard layout, you
can use a post-build process
to also build those files
into your app bundle,
such that if somebody
is playing in Spanish,
they'll only get the Spanish
localization files and vice
versa.
That's not supported out
of the box yet in Unity,
but it's easy to
do after the fact.
So, as I said, in Unity
it's super simple.
You just-- in you Build
Settings, you just
click that box right
there, Build an App Bundle,
Unity is going to
generate the app bundle
and you can upload that
directly to Google Play
with no extra work
required on your end.
If you click Build and Run,
what Unity is going to do
is it's going to
generate that app bundle,
and then it's going to generate
a temporary APK that you
can test locally on your
machine or with a device that's
attached.
So, again, you're not losing
that fast iteration process,
it all just magically works.
Now, I kind of
mentioned something
about the size limit
increasing from 100 megabytes
to 150 megabytes.
And Unity actually
goes above and beyond
and gives you a really
awesome size warning tool.
So what you can do is you
go into Player Settings,
and you can enable
this size notification.
And what Unity is
going to do is,
if it detects your
app bundle is going
to be over a certain
threshold that you define,
it's going to warn you and it
suggests to basically generate
an APK from that app bundle.
And you can be able to view what
the size of that compressed APK
is generated from
the app bundle.
So it's a really
great tool to of keep
you aware of any size limits
you might be going over
for your game.
Now, another great
tool with app bundles
is once you upload the
app bundle to Google Play,
inside of your Play Console
there's a new section called
the App Bundle Explorer.
And so you can see here this
screenshot is of an app bundle
that I uploaded and I'm
taking a look at it.
And it shows you a lot of
information about what your app
bundle is currently
configured and things
like the amount of
size you're saving
using app bundles compared to
if you just uploaded an APK.
And you can see here it's going
to show all the different APK
configurations that this app
bundle is set up to generate.
So here I basically
set it up such
that the app bundle will be
able to generate APKs based
on different screen densities.
So, again, if somebody downloads
the game on a high density
screen, they're only going to
get the high resolution assets
and nothing else.
Now, as you've seen,
it's really easy in Unity
to build app bundles if you
have a custom build pipeline
or something, it's
also really simple
to use Griddle to build
an app on it as well.
However, there is another
tool called Bundle Tool, which
is an amazing product
you should check out,
so it's available on
GitHub or it's actually
comes with your Unity
editor installation.
And what bundle
tool lets you do is
you can use it from
the command line
in your custom build scripts and
you can generate an app bundle.
And then, additionally, what
you can do with bundle tool
is you can use it
to generate APKs
from that app bundle for
specific device configurations
that you might want to test on.
So you could generate
APKs from your app bundle
to send your QA team, to your
automated testing solutions,
so it makes it really,
really easy to,
again, get all the benefits
of using app bundles
while at the same
time not increasing
your overhead of having to
generate both app bundles
and APKs for testing.
So it's really simple.
And another really
tool to use with bundle
tool is that if you happen to
be distributing in a region
where the Google Play
Store is not available
or if you're distributing on
a store that does not support
app bundles, bundle tool, you
can add one extra step to also
generate a universal
APK from the app bundle
you've generated such
that you can then
use that APK on the stores
where the app bundles are not
supported.
So, again, super easy to do
and not a lot of overhead
to get the benefits.
So that's my little bit
on Android app bundles.
I hope you guys take a look.
There's a lot more information
on the Unity documentation,
as well as the Android
Developer documentation.
So now going to hand
it back off to Fran
to finish off with
some of the plugins
that we've built for Unity,
for Google Play Feature Store
Sport.
Thanks.
FRANCESCO CARUCCI: And some
of the plugins are, what?
Play instant.
We talked at length just before
this talk about play instant,
so I'm not going to
go through it anymore.
In a nutshell
it's, if you create
a game that is less than 10
megabytes of the [INAUDIBLE]
you have you can run
it very, very fast
and basically run it
straight off a URL, which
is also a great experience.
To do it in Unity, we provide
the Play Instant plugin,
which basically is as
simple as the screen,
you say you want to generate
an instant build out
of your big Unity
game, and off it goes.
It does everything
that you normally
would have done manually, to
generate an APK that you can
upload straight into
the Google Play Instant
track on Google Play.
Google Play Instant was my first
job at Google two years ago.
I'm pretty new, still.
And I work with my
very good friends here,
they are here on this game,
Panda Pop from Jam City.
This is a hilarious story here.
It was my first
job here at Google.
I was having a meeting
with Vanessa from Jam City.
And then I went back home
and my kid was playing,
he's 3-year-old, Panda Pop,
talk about bringing work home.
So I took a photo of him
playing with Panda Pop, sent it
to Vanessa, she's like,
oh, my god, that's so cute.
She sent him a plush
toy with a panda.
My kid still use
it to go to sleep.
And then he sends back
to Vanessa a video.
Thank you.
And then, now my kid
is five years old
and he's having regular business
breakfast with Jam City.
It's like he's fast tracked
into the game industry.
I hope he doesn't follow me.
But making this
game as a Unity game
was pretty straightforward,
even if it was literally
the first ever Unity game
to be released in Instant.
And that was a great experience.
Now we're going to show
you a bunch of games--
this video is about a minute, a
bunch of games made with Unity.
I worked with at least
one of the games here.
And there's the video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cool.
That's it.
We're done.
Thank you.
[LOGO MUSIC]